das ist eine sehr sehr schlechte Idee
sie werden in Kartei ist wir in
Deutschland selbst wenn wir 80 Millionen
schauen Hand aufs Herz interessiert das
interessiert niemanden eine Party auf
den Gräbern von 15.000 Menschen du sagst
Party go warum weil es sich nicht ändern
wenn man wegschaut soll mehr Leute
hingucken Video umgebracht werden
tausende Tote Arbeiter Homosexualität
steht unter Strafe und fürs Klima eine
Katastrophe trotzdem findet sich statt
die WM in Katar unbedingt boykottieren
sagt Micky beisenherz während Jonas
Hummels das völlig anders sieht und
meint wenn wir alle Hinsehen wird sich
Katar zum Besseren verändern
[Applaus]
spätestens wenn das Turnier beendet ist
und niemand mehr hinguckt fallen
natürlich alle in ihre alten Muster
zurück
[Musik]
ich wette meine letzten vorhandenen
Knorpelzellen in meinem Knien das
Michael jetzt diese WM anschauen wird
[Musik]
also wer mitfeiern boykottieren oder
gibt es irgendwas dazwischen darüber
streiten wir bei mir auf der Couch und
ich verspreche dir es geht um viel mehr
als nur um Fußball ihr beiden herzlich
willkommen Nici nationas Hummels schön
dass Ihr da seid vielen dank vielen Dank
für die Einladung ja freue mich noch
kein Blick für einander ich habe kurz
gewagt
WM in Katar gute Idee oder nicht das ist
eine sehr sehr schlechte Idee sie wärmen
Kartei ist weil es wirklich finde ich
der ultimative
Sündenfall ist klar volle Zustimmung
also ich glaube jeder der weiß nicht bis
1 zählen kann würde diese Meinung
vertreten es ist eigentlich eine fast
eine absolute Tragödie eigentlich wir
sind uns erstmal einig WM in Katar da
gibt es viel zu viel zu kritisieren dran
Haken aber auch dann ist jetzt so Toni
Kroos hat schön gesagt fakt ist das
Turnier wird stattfinden WM gucken WM
boykottieren oder eben nicht klare kurze
Antwort von euch Jonas du zuerst WM
schon kurz und klar Micky nicht gucken
nicht gucken dann helfen wir beide wir
gehen tiefer in euren Streit schön dass
Ihr da seid ich habe mich selber damit
wochenlang und monatelang
auseinandergesetzt ob ich diese WM
überhaupt schauen will nachdem ich alle
Seiten oder beide Seiten in dem Fall
betrachtet habe glaube ich das wichtiger
ist hinzuschauen und aufzuklären als
wegzuschauen ich bin aber nicht allzu
pessimistisch sondern er realistisch
wenn ich sage das ist durchaus etwas
auslösen kann wenn Zuschauer fehlen weil
dann halt einfach irgendwann das Geld
fehlt ganz konkret geht es ja um tote
Arbeiter es geht um die Rechte von
Homosexuelle es geht um Frauen die
unterdrückt werden und da will ich jetzt
mit den beiden rein ja ist das ist das
eine Teambuilding-Maßnahme die du mit
uns
ich habe Bilder rausgesucht die uns zur
WM vielleicht gerade mehr oder zumindest
auf dem zweiten Blick dann vielleicht
auch noch erstmal weniger beschäftigen
ihr pickt bitte die Bilder raus die euch
am meisten
vielleicht triggern sagen wir so läuft
der Rückseite steht was drauf da bitte
ich euch das dann einmal vorzulesen wer
fängt an Micky du siehst gerade schon so
das Bild was mich also Hitler ist
natürlich sehr sehr einfach so aber der
hat ja jetzt der war ja nie Teamchef in
dem Sinne deswegen nehme ich jetzt das
Bild wenn du musst jetzt schauen nachdem
das dann einmal vorlesen was hinten
drauf steht
für Qatar gibt es eine neue
Kapitänsbinde ein Herz in bunten
Streifen die Aufschrift One Love soll
ein Zeichen für Vielfalt setzen zuvor
hatte Manuel Neuer immer die offizielle
Regenbogenflagge der lgbtq+ Bewegung als
Kapitänsbinde getragen so warum nimmst
du das als erstes also für mich ist es
exemplarisch für die verschämte Haltung
der FIFA aber in diesem Falle des DFB
gegenüber ihren eigenen Werten die sie
ja sonst immer extrem zur Schau stellen
und da wo es dann mal wirklich um etwas
geht wo es gilt und zwar im
Ausrichterland Katar da versteckt man
dann plötzlich die Regenbogenfarben
wieder so völlig verschämt in so einem
Herz das ist eigentlich sehr sehr
exemplarisch für diese gebrauchsethik
mit der man auch in dieses Turnier geht
also man will zwar ein Zeichen setzen
aber halt eben nicht so laut und
deutlich dass das irgendwem von den
Gastgebern ich glaube das muss man in
dem Fall auch nicht Gendern unangenehm
auffällt du brauchst Ethik schönes Wort
was hast du bei dieser Kapitänsbinde die
jetzt angepasst wird mit Micky hat gut
gesagt ich finde das ist
also mich triggert das schon auch jetzt
nicht in demselben Maß glaube ich Mickey
wer nicht dein erstes Bild gewesen wenn
ich mein erstes Bild gewesen nee aber es
ist ja dafür ist mit Symbolik fast schon
wieder zu klein da finde ich kann man
bessere
bessere Symbole gebrauchen ich finde die
Symbolik die ist auf einer anderen Art
extrem stark nur nicht das Symbol was
soll die Symbolik ist ist es relativ
deutlich und zwar wenn es dann um den
Kommerz geht dann sind wir auch Willens
unsere eigenen Werte hinten anzustellen
es gab sicherlich schrecklichere Bilder
beispielsweise die Bilder von den
Unterkünften der Arbeiterinnen und
Arbeiter in Katar aber was mich wirklich
am meisten getriggert hat deswegen hatte
ich das Bild ja auch ausgewählt ist halt
die Binde die denn sagen wir legen eine
Schippe drauf damit wir uns besser sieht
schwarze Trikots der Sponsor will nicht
gesehen werden in dem Land wie nimmst du
das war wenn du mir sogar vorstellen
dass es wahrscheinlich sogar dass sich
best verkaufen der dänische Trikot ist
seit zumindest seit 1992 wahrscheinlich
schätzen also wenn die Leistung
entsprechend auch noch ist wird es
wahrscheinlich durch die Decke gehen
weil es ja super du sagst es ja richtig
super simpel ist Haltung zu beweisen und
auf die Art und Weise dann halt nebenbei
noch für ein super Image zu sagen Jonas
welches triggert dich am meisten genau
also da gibt es auf jeden Fall jedes
triggert mich hat am meisten dass sie
getriggert für unseren torbjubel starben
15.000 Menschen wer Fußball liebt darf
über die Toten Arbeitsmigranten in Katar
nicht schweigen dort ausgetragene WM
findet symbolisch auf deren Gräbern
statt Samia el ursil im Spiegel hat das
gesagt wenn man dann diese Arbeitslager
sieht und sowas das macht natürlich die
oder ruft er diese Wut über die Vergabe
wieder hervor und das war tatsächlich
also mein guter guter move muss man
sagen von Leon aber es war für mich eher
eher schwer anzuschauen 15.000 tote eine
Zahl über die auch immer wieder
gestritten wird ich glaube dass tausende
gestorben sind darüber streitet keiner
mehr eine WM als Party auf Gräbern hast
du das vermutet bei dem Bild dass das ja
voll voll das steht natürlich also ich
meine das ist ein fast schon gut
ausgestattetes Arbeitslager für Katar
muss man sagen also da gab es auch
Bilder die man
noch noch viel erschreckender also ich
finde es stehen so ein bisschen
symbolhaft für diese gesamte WM also in
einem Land in dem es keine oder keine
Infrastruktur gehabt in denen die
Stadien zu ja 99 Prozent wahrscheinlich
nicht wirklich wieder Verwendung finden
danach in einem Land das runtergeheizt
wird dann eine Klimakrise in der Berufs
finden Energiekrise der uns befinden ist
das einfach eigentlich die Absurdität
überhaupt also diese Fotos haben
natürlich dafür gesorgt dass diese Wut
wieder zum Vorschein kam die
ursprünglich bei dieser Vergabe
entstanden ist also so dieses warum dort
warum mitten in der Wüste warum in diese
Ressourcenverschwendung im Winter warum
in diese in dieser menschenrechtswidrige
Situation hinein aber nur weil man ja
irgendwie darüber berichtet kann man
vielleicht auch was ändern die kritische
Frage übergebe ich da im Gegenpart auch
verkauft na es ist ein sportlicher
vulgarismus der da nur wirklich sein
absoluten Zenit erlebt das du hast ja
eben schon gesagt nicht gucken ich
feiere nicht mit genau du sagst doch
partygo warum weil es sich nicht ändern
wenn man wegschaut also jetzt ist das
ganze Jahr viel viel zu spät
dieser also die Vergabe war 2010/2017
wurden Menschenrechte in diese ganze
Vergabe Kriterien erstmal hinzugefügt
aber hinschauen werden wir sowieso noch
alleine schon deshalb weil es andere
Länder gibt wird zum Beispiel
Saudi-Arabien oder Katar auch wenn es um
die Energieversorgung geht das heißt wir
werden sowieso gezwungen sein
hinzuschauen allerdings auf Grundlage
anderer in Anführungsstrichen Events ich
sage ganz ehrlich ich hatte erst Sorge
dass das hier nach 5 Minuten fertig ist
der eine sagt Boykott der andere sagt
nein aber schon jetzt in diesem Streit
merken wir wie viel da drin steckt und
wie viel gleich noch kommen kann guter
Punkt und vielleicht das nächste Bild
mal zu nehmen also eher triggert mich in
diesem Falle eher muss ich fast schon
sagen humoristisch aber ist ja selber
immer auch gefühlt 100% getriggert Uli
Hoene ist Doppelpunkt die wl-prozess
Engagement des FC Bayern in der
Golfregion der wird dazu führen dass die
Arbeitsbedingungen für die Arbeit dazu
hat besser werden das sollte man endlich
mal akzeptieren und nicht ständig auf
die Leute drauf haben eines ist klar den
Arbeiter den Kata geht es durch die WM
besser und viel schlechter jetzt muss
man natürlich dazu wissen der FC Bayern
hat ja sowieso eine Partnerschaft mit
Katar da gibt es weiß ich nicht 17
Millionen oder so im Jahr also da kommt
schon ganz ordentlich was an Geld
zusammen und dieser Satz den Arbeitern
geht es in Katar durch die WM besser und
nicht schlechter da gibt es ja nun
relativ aktuelle Berichte von Amnesty
International dass das eben nicht so ist
also ich sehe das natürlich nicht anders
aber ich glaube wenn man eben diese
Brücken überhaupt irgendwie bauen will
dann muss man anfangen in diesem Diskurs
eben zu sein und wenn man ein bisschen
diese ganze Region versteht oder auch
wie wie wie sensibel diese Leute da vor
Ort sind und ohne die geht ja nun mal
nicht wenn man eben nur drauf hat und
rauf und drauf hat dann machen die noch
mehr zu das kommen wir zum nächsten Bild
glaube ich mal du darfst das
zurückpinnen in Jonas du darfst ein
neues auswählen genau dann nehme ich das
passt ja jetzt hintereinander
dramaturgisch super exakt bleiben
also soweit ich weiß das muss man auch
mal dazu also ich habe dieses Bild
genommen Demokratisierung und
Liberalisierungen durch sportliche
Großveranstaltungen sei es im Fußball
Beispiel Chile 62 78 Russland 2018 oder
bei Olympischen Spielen Beispiele Berlin
36 Peking 22 finden de facto nicht statt
und dienen nicht selten zu
Stabilisierung und und weltweiten
Geltung von unrechtsregimen also ich
habe vermutet dass es um sportwashing
geht durch großartig
funktionierende Sport Ereignisse und ich
sein Gewissen sondern eher sein sein
politisches Bild oder das Bild ist man
nach außen abgibt ein bisschen zu
verbessern mir geht es eher darum dass
die Leute anfangen zu verstehen dass
fußballpolitik eingebilde ist das ist
für dich Micky ein Vergleich der Klage
dass man die WM in Katar irgendwie
gedanklich in Verbindung bringt mit den
Olympischen Spielen unter Adolf Hitler
wenn es wenn es um Sport und Politik die
Verflechtung geht und Sport und der
Imagegewinn einer Nation denn darum geht
es ja in erster Linie dann ist das
natürlich ein absolut zulässiges
Beispiel exakt trotzdem muss ich dazu
sagen hat dieses Bild auch etwas
insofern Hoffnung stiftendes Olympia 36
war ja auch der Moment als Jesse Owens
als ich glaube Sprinter und als
Weitspringer er brillierte und Gold
geholt hat
und das war natürlich im Wohnzimmer von
Adolf Hitler also es gab ja noch weitere
Beispiele bei Olympia genau Black Power
da kriege ich jetzt noch Gänsehaut
deswegen finde ich so so so passend weil
es ja eine riesige Bühne ist im wahrsten
Sinne und diese Bühne kann man dann eben
nutzen und das ist ja quasi in dieser
Argumentation der ich so ein bisschen
versucht zu folgen so genau dann wenn
eben alle hinschauen dann kann man
vielleicht auch was bewegen da kann man
vielleicht auch was machen wir als
Moderatorin oder Kommentatoren planen
die Weltmeisterschaft natürlich nicht
einfach so zu berichten wie eine normale
Weltmeisterschaft weil weil es keine
normale Weltmeisterschaft ist wir wollen
kritisch berichten wir wollen berichten
darüber was gibt es für gute Sachen was
kann man verbessern was wurde ich
bereits vielleicht verbessert wir werden
wahrscheinlich vielleicht noch über
diese Thematik sprechen aber ich kann
sie ja trotzdem mal anreißen das
triggert mich natürlich insofern
als dieses Bild im krassen Widerspruch
steht zu dem was wir gerade besprochen
haben denn dieses Bild ist ja eine sehr
kutao vor Katar vor einem System
deren werten wir nicht entsprechend dass
uns aber mit etwas beliefert was wir
brauchen Energie so und also die
Grundlast und die Grundversorgung das
steht aber im totalen Widerspruch zum
Sport denn der Sport so sehr wie ihn
lieben und das Betrachten von Sport
Ereignissen ist natürlich nicht unsere
Grundversorgung und wir sind nicht davon
abhängig wichtiger Punkt Gas viel
wichtiger als Sport wie siehst du das
wenn du dieses Foto jetzt siehst klar
das unterschreibe ich sofort diese ganze
Positur du hast es ja angesprochen ist
ein bisschen okay wir werfen sie im
ganzen unter wir passen uns an
prinzipiell habe ich kein Problem damit
weil das auch ein Zeichen von Respekt
das gegenüber anderen Kultur und nur
weil das vielleicht nicht unser Werte
sind das ist eine Kultur die wir
respektieren lasst uns zurück zum
Fußball und zurück auf die Couch kommen
ja vielen Dank
[Musik]
bis hierhin das Thema ist ziemlich
kompliziert haben wir gerade an vielen
Fotos und vielen Aspekten schon gesehen
ob so kompliziert ist naja ich hatte
schon den Eindruck wir müssen über WM
reden aber gleichzeitig müssen wir
plötzlich über Hitler und Olympische
Spiele reden es kommt Gas ins Spiel wir
reden über Saudi Arabien es ist schon
viel drin du sagst trotzdem nicht
kompliziert warum weil selten hat man
als Individuum im Kollektiv ja eine
solche Wirkmacht wie in diesem Falle ich
hätte es ja auch gefragt ja so schaue
ich mir diesen Quatsch in der Wüste an
also gebe ich mir das will ich
irgendwelche Funktionäre sehen die sich
die Hände schütteln und das Kollektiv
schafft ist doch nur wenn Messi Ronaldo
im bappé Neymar nicht mitspielen was die
beiden hier besprechen nennen wir in der
Psychologie Selbstwirksamkeit habe ich
als Person das Gefühl dass ich was
bewirken kann brechen was runter machen
was mal ganz einfach gucken oder eben
boykottieren und jetzt sagst du obwohl
das was du gerade beschreibst du würdest
es trotzdem gucken ja während Micky sagt
wir haben doch jetzt als Kollektiv die
Chance zu sagen nein vielleicht gehen
wir dann ganz konkret da mal tiefer rein
warum du gibst natürlich alles aus der
Hand wenn du wegschaust also jetzt ist
es wie gesagt so der Fisch stinkt vom
Kopf in dem Fall relativ gewaltig das
ist dieses ganz Vergabe System die FIFA
ja selber wie werden diese diese
Wettbewerbe denn vergeben also was gibt
es für klären es gab keine Kriterien
2010 das heißt man muss da vielleicht
mal anfangen der FIFA nicht mehr das
Feld zu überlassen ein entscheidendes
Kriterium ist er bei der Vergabe eines
was sich nie ändern wird was aber in
diesem Zusammenhang vielleicht auch sehr
hilfreich ist denn da wo die Zuschauer
sind da sind die Sponsoren obwohl die
Sponsoren sind ist das Geld wenn dieses
Turnier nicht geguckt wird dann ist das
für die FIFA und vor allem für die
Sponsoren einfach keine lohnende
Investition und ich finde
diese Welle einmal brechen kannst das
schafft ja nur das Kollektiv das
Kollektiv schafft ist doch nur wenn
Messi Ronaldo im bapei Neymar nicht
mitspielen nur dann schaut das grob wir
in Deutschland selbst wenn wir 80
Millionen schauen Hand aufs Herz
interessiert das interessiert niemanden
ja das ist natürlich eine sehr
pessimistische Sicht das ist doch so die
die ich jetzt auch nicht völlig also die
unterscheidet sich jetzt auch nicht so
massiv ganz nebenbei sind drei von den
vier die ich gerade genannt habe deren
Arbeitgeber ist Katar wenn man sagt okay
man schaut nicht da kann man ja auch gar
nicht Pessimist oder Optimist sein
sondern man liegt einfach die Hände in
den Schoß und man sagt okay hier sind
meine meine Waffen die existieren nicht
ich als Konsument habe eben keine Chance
außer nicht schauen es geht mir ja nur
darum dass es ja das ist ja theoretisch
ja wirklich zu schaffen ist sich einem
Turnier einmal zu verweigern um es zu
schaffen das klar ist okay wir haben
jetzt den Punkt also wir als FIFA haben
den Punkt überschritten jetzt ist es
halt wirklich jetzt berichten dass das
so der Fall wäre
Individuum habe ich eine Verantwortung
und spiele ich die aus oder sage ich ich
bin ja nur einer von 80 Millionen und am
Ende einer nur von 8 Milliarden es macht
keinen Unterschied nee das macht dann
Unterschied in welcher Konsequenz man
das macht jetzt ein zu mir zu
boykottieren und dann wieder ganz normal
zu schauen und ich schaue weiter
Champions League und kaufe meine Paris
saint-germain-trikots und meine Bayern
Trikots mit dem schönen Qatar RWS auf
dem Ärmel das verändert natürlich nicht
im Großen und Ganzen als Konsument da
bin ich der fest Überzeugung hast du
immer eine Chance wir sprechen aber auch
gerade über das Individuum wer macht's
einzeln bevor wir wieder auf das ganz
große Feld des riesigen Geldes dann
gehen wo der einzelne zu beiträgt ein
einzelner steht auf und zwar ein Fan vor
dem Botschafter aus Katar und sagt
folgendes ich bin ein Mann und ich liebe
Männer ich habe Sex mit Männern gewöhnen
sie sich daran oder bleiben sie dem
Fußball fern wie geht's dir hast du das
gesehen hast ich fand das ein sehr
berührenden Moment was ist natürlich
wirklich die auch die die maximale
Konfrontation wahrscheinlich auch
beleidigend aus seiner Perspektive wenn
man sich vorstellt dass ein Land ist in
dem Menschen im Zweifel die Todesstrafe
bekommen wenn sie nur sexuell sich sich
offen zeigen natürlich hat mir das gut
gefallen wenngleich ich und da bin ich
dann eher bei Jonas dann auch schon
mittlerweile mit so viel
Ernüchterung auf solche Sachen Blicke
dass ich auf weiß das ist eine tolle
Geste also ich habe fast Tränen Augen
gehabt um ehrlich zu sein also mich hat
es nicht nur berührt sondern mich hat es
auch fast schon zum Verzweifeln gebracht
weil ich mir dachte das ist der eine der
steht auf und ist genau das was alle
nehmen es auf alle nehmen es natürlich
auch irgendwie wohlwollend auf weil sie
denken okay da ist jemand der tut jemand
was im Idealfall hat jeder diese Courage
aber die Hauptakteure sind die Spieler
das ist einfach so und das wird auch so
sein und wenn die etwas machen würden
und wenn die sich im Kollektiv zusammen
sind aber das müssen dann alle sein so
dass da am Ende werde ich für die
Nationalmannschaft berufen weil alle
anderen abgesagt haben so ungefähr lasst
uns da gleich tiefer noch mal reingehen
ganz spannender Punkt erstmal jetzt
vielleicht noch mal maximale Klarheit
hilft mir Platz zu schaffen den brauchen
wir dafür noch
[Musik]
da sind zwei Medienprofis und die sind
natürlich abgebrüht und tänzeln hier
gerade so ein bisschen umeinander rum
wie beim Boxkampf beim Aufwärmen ich
will jetzt das wirklich die Fetzen
fliegen und deswegen müssen jetzt ganz
konkret sagen wo stehen Sie und schreien
für Fußballfans brauchen im Stadion ja
die Botschaft manchmal ziemlich klar auf
einem Banner dass man auch noch nach
zwei drei Stadion Pilz versteht und
diese Banner habe ich jetzt mal für euch
mitgebracht klare Botschaft jetzt zur
Frage WM boykottieren oder nicht was ist
dein dein Kernpunkt nein Satz bis
hierhin und es ist gut ein bisschen
Druck aufzubauen
[Musik]
du twitterst den ganzen Tag was soll das
denn jetzt jonas ist schon fast fertig
wenn Adolf Hitler nicht vorkommt in
diesem Text
Idee ist jetzt folgende ja wir stellen
uns ein riesiges Fußballstadion vor 360
Grad und Richtung Fans Richtung Kamera
ist das fällt euch bestimmt auf den
ersten Blick wer aber hier wurde schon
geschrien und hier muss auch wieder
geschrieben werden auf dieser Couch haut
mal bitte euren Spruch so raus wie Fans
das jetzt machen wenn richtig skandieren
und sie lauter ihr das kriegt umso
überzeugender wird das erstmal wirken
bitte schön hinschauen ist bitte schaut
hin schau hin und habt Kritik
hinschaut
hin setzt euch damit auseinander ja
schreien ist nicht so mein Ding also ich
bin jetzt auch nicht der der
Lautsprecher da hat sich Micky natürlich
in seiner entertainerrolle ein bisschen
wohler gefühlt Mensch ist mittelplan weg
wegschauen ist mit Hitler ich habe mich
in der Situation dass das Schreiens
nicht besonders wohl gefühlt weil ich
generell kein großer Freund von
Schreierei bin das geschieht mir bei
Twitter schon täglich auf andere Art und
Weise wer wegschaut machten Fehler
kritisch kritischer Auseinandersetzung
Diplomatie und Diskurs sollte ich
genieße es so sehr vor allem weil du
noch adaptiert hast wunderbar darf ich
euch die abnehmen wenn wir so vergleiche
aufmachen mit hitlern oder die
Olympischen Spiele im Dritten Reich
jetzt mit der WM in Katar dann springt
in unserem Kopf sofort eine Bewertung an
ist dieser Vergleich passend ist das
eine nicht viel schlimmer als das andere
darum geht es den beiden hier aber nicht
die wollen die Bilder die Gefühle die
Emotionen die in ihnen wirken greifbar
machen und dann ist so ein Vergleich
okay eure Botschaft ist so klar
hinschauen ist mit Hitler heißt dass man
sich tolerant gegenüber einem
diktatorischen System zeigt aber
verändern kann man es natürlich nicht
wenn man gar nichts macht dann ist man
natürlich noch mehr in seinen alten
Gewohnheit also im positivsten aller
Sinne veränderst du es vielleicht
kurzfristig aber langfristig Ausbeutung
von Menschen ist natürlich
wirtschaftlich immer wesentlich besser
weil effizienter als langfristig für
gute Arbeitsbedingungen zu sorgen und
warum sollen sie es verändern wenn der
Rest der Welt schon längst wieder
woanders hinkommt aber warum sollte
niemand jemals hingeschaut hat die
Alternative wäre wir lassen Katar
komplett ich will das überhaupt nicht
gut heißen überhaupt nicht aber wir
lassen die einfach alleine in ihrer
Gemengelage das ist ein das ist ein
islamisches arabisches Land von dem wir
vielleicht wo wir die Kultur nicht so
richtig gut verstehen wo wir nicht
wissen okay was passiert denn da
überhaupt und die Alternative einfach zu
sagen interessiert uns nicht Fußballfans
mit dem Schild anschreien ist das eine
hat gut funktioniert wir haben jetzt
ganz klar wo die beiden stehen aber ich
will wissen was passiert wenn jemand
anfängt mal wirklich kritisch
nachzufragen
[Musik]
die beiden bitte einmal auf die Couch
einfach Platz nehmen denn wir haben
jetzt etwas vor wo wir noch ein bisschen
Stimmung für brauchen Ihr kennt
vielleicht folgendes Phänomen man macht
irgendwas und ist trotzdem der Meinung
es geht komplett gegen meine Werte nennt
man in der Psychologie kognitive
Dissonanz ich bin eigentlich für ahm tue
trotzdem B ja und bei dieser WM könnte
man ja sagen wir sind alle hoffentlich
für die Rechte von lgbtq Communitys wir
sind alle gegen irgendwelches missachten
der Frauenrechte und so weiter wir
wollen nicht das Arbeiter sterben und
trotzdem wird es Leute geben die das
gucken und ich will jetzt wissen was ist
denn dann im Kopf von Jonas los der
jetzt als Vater seinem süßen Sohn Mickey
erklärt wieso wir denn die WM doch
geguckt haben Micky du wirst jetzt
dieser Sohn und legst dich mal bitte so
bei deinem Papa auf den Schoß auf der
Couch dann werde es nachts
[Musik]
okay Papa ja sind doch ganz viele
Menschen gestorbene katal wurden alle
umgebracht warum hast du das denn
trotzdem geguckt das zu dir sagt man
bringt keine Leute um das das ist auch
so und das sollte man noch nicht tun und
man sollte es auch nicht unterstützen
aber ja man muss den die Leute auch
bisschen erziehen im Sinne von man muss
den Leuten zeigen was dort passieren
dann dürfen die Leute umbringen und dann
gehst du hin und sagst mach das nicht
und guckst trotzdem nein aber man muss
die Aufmerksamkeit dazu generieren das
ist eben schlechte mehr Leute hingucken
Video umgebracht werden das wäre im
Zweifel gar nicht so schlecht weil dann
mehr Leute verstehen dass es falsch ist
und dass solche vergaben falsch aber
wenn ich jetzt jemanden wenn ich jetzt
hier beim Stein auf dem Kopf haue dann
holst du ganz viele Leute die sollen
sich das angucken was gestehen jetzt
muss ich mir gerade selber mal ins
Gesicht gucken analysieren da versucht
einer in der Rolle das Psychotherapeuten
zu bleiben und hat große Schwierigkeiten
weil es irgendwie so lustig ist nee die
Tat bleibt dieselbe die bleibt falsch
und ihr sollt doch nicht tun und das
solltest du auch in der Zukunft nicht
machen aber wenn mehr Leute verstehen
dass das falsch ist dann verstehst auch
du leichter dass es falsch ist und nur
mehr Leute zu ja aber dadurch verschafft
man sich eine mehr Aufmerksamkeit und
mehr Bewusstsein leute wenn ich jemanden
Stein auf dem Kopf hauen genau dann
machst du es beim nächsten Mal nicht
mehr weil immer mehr Leute sagen das ist
falsch ist generell mag ich das andere
Perspektiven einzunehmen weil man ist
natürlich gefangen in seiner in seiner
Bubble in seinem ich sag jetzt mal in
diesem confirmation beides Wahnsinn
Micky also ganz kurz diese
schauspielerischen Leistungen das war
gefühlt kein Schauspieler es muss echt
gewesen sein
bitte kriegt ihr das zu zweit hin einmal
jetzt Jonas
[Musik]
selbe Frage dein Sohn liegt auf deinem
Schoß und will jetzt von dir ganz
kritisch wissen und Jonas übernimmst als
Kind Papa ja
was ist eigentlich ein Katar damals
passiert du meinst warum ich das nicht
geguckt habe das Turnier der
Bundeskanzler von Katar das ist
eigentlich ganz böser Mann der hat
Regeln in seinem Land und damit bin ich
nicht einverstanden und du übrigens auch
nicht du kennst doch den Onkel Jürgen
und den Onkel Günther so und die beiden
haben sich ja ganz lieb so und die
könnten zum Beispiel in Katar könnten
die gar nicht so über die Straße gehen
wie sie das bei uns in Castrop-Rauxel
machen so weil die nämlich dann würden
die nämlich aufgehängt werden und werden
werden da jetzt immer noch Onkel Jürgen
und Onkel Peter aufgehängt ja die werden
da immer noch aufgehängt so da war
nämlich dann für einen Monat lang das
Turnier in Katar das Fußball und du
weißt wie sehr ich wie sehr ich Fußball
liebe ich gucke immer Fußball und damals
nicht damals habe ich es nicht geguckt
weil ich wollte dass der Bundeskanzler
von Katar versteht dass ich und hat das
verstanden
ja
manche sagen ja manche sagen nein aber
ich selber wollte das nicht unterstützen
ja auch als als Sechsjährige habt ihr
schon gemerkt da fehlen einfach auch so
gewisse Stilmittel und da fehlt
vielleicht auch ein bisschen Intellekt
um das Ganze rüberzubringen damit auch
wir sechsjähriges verstehen aber kann
ich ihm gerne noch mal beibringen wird
es langsam wieder Tag ihr dürft
aufstehen
[Musik]
es war lustig es war voller Humor und
das ist Psychologie eben auch nicht nur
düster sondern gerade wenn die Themen
schwierig sind kann Humor unglaublich
helfen Jonas du hast keine Kinder
glaubst du aber als Sohn wärst du mit
dir und deiner Papa Erklärung zufrieden
gewesen schwierig also wahrscheinlich
eher nicht weil ich diesen Zusammenhang
überhaupt nicht erklären kann in so
einfachen Sätzen Micky du hast eine
kleine Tochter ja will die gucken nee
glaub nicht wenn die gucken wollte
würdest du sagen nee geht nicht wird es
Dir so erklären wie Jonas oder was seine
darfst ich will ich glaube ich würde
tatsächlich sie wahrscheinlich sogar
eher gucken lassen weil ich finde es
immer ein bisschen problematisch Kinder
in so jungen Jahren gleich schon so zu
überfrachten mit den eigenen moralischen
Wertvorstellungen was wir alle Einzel
machen ist ein Punkt vielleicht mal über
die Spieler gesprochen dein Bruder
berühmter Spieler der ja auch schon in
Situationen gewesen sein muss wo ich mir
vorstelle dass da auch in dem
spielerkopf doch ganz viel
wahrscheinlich ein umtreibt oder ist es
so dass das dann Mats Hummel sagt wenn
er auf dem Platz geht blende ich alles
aus man muss verstehen was bedeutet
Fußballprofi zu sein und ich mache den
Fußballern da tatsächlich gar nicht so
den riesenvorbruch ich wünsche mir würde
mir freuen dass es mehr Fußballer gibt
wieso Karte ist oder andere politische
Sportler ich glaube die
Zeiten sind vorbei dass wir die sich
Fußball ausbilden im wahrsten Sinne oder
das für die so erziehen wollen dass Sie
sich irgendwie eine Meinung bilden und
da dass sie diese frei äußern den Zug
haben wir wirklich vor Jahren
das ist vorbei ja das wird nicht mehr
Geld das wird nicht gewollt das wird von
niemanden weder die Sponsoren noch die
Vereine ich glaube das wird einfach die
Leute werden ja mundtot gemacht dieses
dahin gehen als Spieler und spielen da
ist es für dich okay zu sagen da bin ich
unpolitisch da blende ich das politische
aus politischen muss man sein deswegen
ist vielleicht auch dieses wegducken des
DFBs was ja ewig und auch glaube ich
immer noch eigentlich stattfindet der
falsche Weg sondern nimm die Spieler mit
an die Hand erziehe sie dahin und sorgt
dafür dass weil die haben Einfluss das
sind im wahrsten Sinne influencer ich
glaube dass die Sportler politisch
werden könnten wenn es die wenn es das
System drumherum ist zulassen würde wir
hatten die Kinder wir hatten jetzt noch
mal ganz persönlich auch eure Standpunkt
und wir haben sie eben angeschnitten die
Spieler die auch eine riesige Reichweite
haben und eine Position bekommen jetzt
fehlen mir noch so ein bisschen die
jeweilige Dirigenten Rolle bei den
Spielern ich habe was vorbereitet zum
Schluss wo ich noch gucken möchte ob wir
da was zusammen hinbekommen noch einmal
Platz bitte
[Musik]
es ist so ein riesen Thema und alle
müssen irgendwie konkret aber auch ja am
Ende damit umgehen Oliver Bierhoff haben
sie Flick eure beiden Rollen sie haben
Sie vielleicht kannst du gerne um das
für Dich pass auf du stellt euch gerne
mal dahin ich bin der anzusprechende
Teil der Nationalmannschaft wir stellen
uns vor Kabine vor dem ersten Spiel
Katar WM die beiden Trainer haben sich
jetzt was überlegt was sie den Spielern
mitgeben um zu sagen so können wir
vielleicht doch ein Zeichen setzen so
können wir was machen bevor jetzt alle
ausrasten die Crew hat mir gerade auch
schon gesagt Oliver Bier auf ist Manager
nicht Trainer ich interessiere mich
nicht für Fußball interessiere mich für
Psychologie und die steckt ja wohl auch
drin
[Musik]
an die Spieler und so wie ihr die
anfeuern würdet wäre die jetzt
motivieren würde weil die müssen ja alle
mitmachen gleich so pass mal auf ihr
Arschlöcher also folgendermaßen läuft
gleich ihr geht da raus ihr gewinnt das
Spiel ihr Haut Frankreich 3:0 weg und
nach dem ersten Tor macht jetzt mach was
am Tor oder vom Spielen vom Spieler mit
zusammen mit Mannschaftsrat ein Trikot
entwickelt das habt ihr über eurem
normalen Trick und unter der Jacke und
in dem Moment in dem das Foto vor dem
Spiel das gemeinsame Foto und ihr steht
Hand in Hand
zusammen habt ihr einen Trikot der
Nationalmannschaft in Regenbogenfarben
an und zieht hier an und dann zeigen wir
nämlich mal den ganzen Pfeifen was
westliche Werte sind ne wir sind ja
schließlich nicht nur zum Fußball
spielen hier sondern wir stehen ja auch
für Europa wir stehen ja für westliche
Werte und ihr Tröten ihr macht das jetzt
und nichts verstanden
machen wir Plan B neuer du küsst
Goretzka auf dem Mund und dann geht's ja
so wird es irgendwie laufen Micky Jonas
riesen Thema immer wieder auch ist uns
eure Motor begegnet was mich sehr
gefreut hat und trotzdem bleibt ein
ernstes und schwieriges Thema nach der
WM sehen wir uns privat vielleicht noch
mal wieder auf einer Couch zur
Paartherapie ansonsten spätestens zur
nächsten Staffel sagen
also ein Kompromiss zu finden der da
lautet wir gucken jetzt das eine Spiel
ja das andere nicht da halte ich es dann
mit Adorno es gibt kein richtiges Leben
im falschen also ich glaube meine
Position würde dich wirklich schon
irgendwo ein bisschen in die weiter in
die Mitte gerückt über dein Ende bin ich
wieder zurückgerutscht weil ich mir
denke so das ändert er nichts dann
schaue ich weg und was passiert dann so
dann probiere ich lieber meine
Möglichkeiten zu nutzen und mich selber
auch mehr zu informieren und selber
diese diese Bühne
ja einfach zu nutzen ich zeig mir noch
ein paar Tipps und hoffe du hast die
Folge so genau wie ich war ein bisschen
lustiger ein bisschen anders als sonst
aber gestritten wird ja auch ein
psychologisch war es auch und damit
geht's direkt weiter jetzt in der ZDF
Mediathek
[Musik]